good morning mission my name is Evan
Carmichael buy one word and believe as I
believe that monsters will solve all of
the world's major problems so Hilton on
your journey
today's messages create the best
products over two buildings amigo
every product we do is absolutely as
capable as it can possibly be
you know there's none Oh holding back we
are the people at Microsoft come into
work every day building the best
products they can and they're very proud
you go out go into schools and see how
kids are using this stuff going ask
people about how their jobs have teams
because of the personal computer you
know we're sitting there listening to
our customers saying how they'd like to
make things better so we're we do
absolutely our best job and in fact
that's why we've been successful you
know anybody who holds back in this
business isn't going to be around for
long because this is a business where
you always have to be moving at a very
rapid pace the number one little easy
money right on this is one of the most
basic rules is the system we're going to
provide the mobile campaign so the
better your fire service is the more
it's helping people divorce providing
value the more your business is a
growing part the challenge is for a lot
of you guys your product or service is
it's actually that good it's okay maybe
get some results leave until the early
days but it isn't actually that good yes
and the market is the test
when you put it out there people start
using your product are they getting a
result it should be something that when
they use your product or use your
service it's instantly noticeable the
value at top and that's how to return
someone who has no brand name don't
recognition coming out of you know left
field nobody's ever heard of this person
has no reputation in the industry can
still win because it's providing so much
in seeing value the example of poisonous
M&Ms is called into various radio
stations and it uses think name he calls
it on LL Cool J's show elephant
returning of Georgia show and he wanted
to rock for him and he called in here
some big names and essence wrapping it
is only one but then you're really good
like you're really really good you
should be auditioning you should be
getting a record deal you should really
focus on this talented you got we've got
something
of course evidence you know one of the
best rappers in the world but the talent
was immediately noticeable even if they
had no idea that was Eminem and so can
you create on that level
are you currently making a product or
service that is on that level to that
when somebody immediately uses it the
existing thing guys I can logical pitch
me all time with their products their
software their apps their tools their
services all the time I get emails every
single day with engines of different
products and some of I look at and I'm
not impressed
it's very early stage it doesn't provide
me enough god I love I love tools that
help save you time and if I'm using a
tool that will save you time will tell
people about it a puzzle guys I'm new to
tell
trying to tell people my network
business pot this service because doing
so much bad for me
probably is what you're sending me is
not to be crazy done and that's okay for
now it's an opportunity to bet this is
where you are now there's very little
market acceptance people are loving what
you're doing improve it make it better
listen to feedback put it back into the
next version at the end of the day you
have to create a great product PR will
help you market will help you you know
but at the end of the day some pieces
this thing actually work does this thing
action solve a problem and you may love
it you may think it's the best thing in
the world but if you have something that
you absolutely love that is not serving
the needs of a market you just have a
option you don't have a business
successful come from both you have to
love what you do and ask the environment
for it let me huge is Emma hop it is
just a market forward you don't like it
you're not going to have success as
people who love that visible question
both what would you do market for it
combine those things by seeing value so
the question today is I'm curious I want
to know a product that you recently
bought that you love those providing the
same value to you for some reason I want
you to share it up don't put your own
products I want to part with somebody
else if you bought that you absolutely
love and what I'm hopefully we do is
kind of learn look these are companies
to a creating brick box which will be
learning them and apply our own business
a concept of model success leave it on
top still all villagers upon that I also
want to give a quick shout out to Devon
trees Devon thank you so much you're
picking up the audio versions of myself
here one word and posted a review on is
my new Instagram page I really
appreciated van
I'm so glad you enjoyed my phone so
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I'll continue to believe
in yourself and whenever you're one
where it is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso if you look at the the
company's been in Dara over decades they
tend to win on product it is true that
it is critical to get sales and
marketing right because without that you
just don't get the flywheel going but I
you know like the most valuable tech
company in the world is Apple and I
think they may like just the best
products across the board I don't know
if Google is still number two but I
think like Google search dominates
everything else and also like most like
Gmail and Google Maps dominated
respective products
I think Airbnb one on product I think
that Facebook although they came late to
the game had like the best product by
far and they've and they've managed to
expand that so I think I don't ever try
to let people off the hook for sales and
marketing because if you build the best
product in the world and don't get
anyone to use it that still kind of
sucks but the I think it is very hard to
win in the long long term without the
best product I think that you can get
acquired two years in because you had a
really good like press or marketing
strategy but that does not that is not
how you create certain enduring value
eventually sort of these things converge
the key thing for us was the product and
our whole focus for the first 10 years
of the company was building a better
mousetrap having a better running shoe
having a better festival should having
more cushioning in different shoes and
innovating like every six months and
spending a lot of money and research and
development spending a lot of money in a
lab and the product process really was
developed far in advance of anything
else that we did we don't believe
there's a tension between products and
business we believe there's a staging
which is in this industry you don't have
a business until you have a product in
particular you don't have a business
so you have a product that a lot of
people want we have this concept we use
a term product market fit which is
basically you have a product that the
market wants and you can tell because
the market is pulling the product and
until you have that time spent building
the business around the product is
pointless because it's not going to go
anywhere like best case it's going to be
a zombie there's a lot of companies are
in the valley as a lot of companies in
the valley and elsewhere that are you
know 25 50 75 people they've got a
product nobody really wants it they sell
a few every quarter and they kind of
geek out a living and they go on for
year after year after year after year
after year and they never get anywhere
they never go public they never get
bought and people just basically collect
salaries and that's not what that's like
not what we want to do and that's not
what's super you know super high
potential entrepreneurs want to do so
what we basically say is if you want to
build a big success you got to nail the
product you got it like it's got to be a
killer product it's got to be something
that has product market fit when you
have product market fit then you build a
company around it right so then you
build a sales force then you start doing
marketing and then you start doing
business deals then you start expanding
internationally and you do all this
other stuff and it's at that point where
you start to apply a lot of capital and
you build a big board and you start
hiring executives and doing all this
stuff but a full executive team with the
sales force and all that stuff before
you have the killer product is a
complete waste of time